اما اما امشي في الشارع بتغلب كثير ممكن
الناس تفضل تتطلع علي واحراج طب مش بتلم
الكرتونه تعملي فيه ايش بتعرض للاحراج مش
كل واحده اقدر اجاوبه
[موسيقى]
وفكر يعمل العاب لانه اولاده بصيحوا بدهم
العاب معوش يشتري لهم بدا يعمل لهم عجلات
بدا يعمل لهم فزب صغيره سياره صغيره
يلعبوا فيها فرحنا في يوم لقيناهم حلوين
[موسيقى]
بالبدايه انا كنت يعني بدور على مجال شغل
يعني بدي اشتغل
فلما دورت بكذا مجاله وما لقيتش فقلت يعني
استغل الاشي اللي انا بعرف اعمله البرجر
هو انك تفتح مشروع اشي مش صعب بس انك تكمل
بالمشروع هو الاشي صعب يعني هنا الصعوبه
بتكون
[موسيقى]
شخصيته يدوي فقط انا وزوجتي
كنا ننقل الرمل وقصرنا نعمل اللي هي حضانه
الصبار ولما طلع اللي هو المنتج فصلت انا
معمل خاص بيا وانا وزوجتي في غرفه الضيوف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]